so get 15 grams of protein in if you're
strength training and if you're adding
in a little bit of cardio at any point
10 or 15 grams of carbohydrate we say
about 30 all up you're looking at maybe
150 calories total before you're doing a
strength and and cardiovascular type
workout otherwise it's around 100
calories from protein fat coffee or
Bulletproof Coffee kind of thing has
been such a craze as fat uh detrimental
or is it just not helpful it takes a
really long time to get out of your
stomach and intestines so it doesn't
really fuel you in any scope of the
matter the thing with Bulletproof Coffee
and all the things that they're like
here's your ncts and your coffee it's
for satiation it's to help with that
okay let's get that cognitive focus and
hold that caffeine because it extends
the half-life of caffeine it also clears
out your blood sugar so you feel like
you're focused but really you're just on
the edge of being hypoglycemic